come on in my friend welcome to the show
nice to be you have a seat right there
you go that would be here than anywhere
is that right no it is because all these
other jokes for shows around here just
terrible finally you found a good one
there you go how is everything yo life
is good man life is good Arthur we just
dropped can you dig it
author I can dig anything so I'm a
martial artist you know businessman is
that what you've always lied in there
have you
pioneer yes I've done a lot of first
necklace maker lot of first what would
you what are you what are you most proud
of being a pioneer for I feel like
you're a pioneer and this is don't take
this the wrong way for the trans
community it's become such a big thing
now when to Wong foo came out that was a
risky move for you for for you in
Leguizamo and and you know actually
wasn't you know thankful no no no it was
so much fun and you know we all had our
perspective careers at that time right
that's why and I had already done
character like that on Broadway so I was
already familiar with it I had gotten
over you know the trauma of putting on
the dress
sure and talking and all that I could
you talk in that movie yeah of course
you got to you got to get a harness you
have to play the role right I had to
talk much too abundant for me to go whoo
yeah I hate to see yeah I really want
Wesley Snipes head inside with like back
braces on my society mistaken [ __ ] rain
roll is all about continuity Rhymes and
continuity right Oh where's our word
word player so I did everybody tuck in
that movie or were you more method I
didn't check yeah I assuming but I don't
really know right that's probably the
right answer there what are you most
proud of for being a pioneer for when we
talk about the yes maybe being in the
business you know and doing the kind of
work that we've done the diversity of
work that we've done yeah
yeah I think that in and of itself has
been a interesting milestone clearly
what we've been able to accomplish early
on with that whole blade project yeah
that's and of itself was you know I love
that something people rolled up and had
made toilet tissue and do it on the wall
and hope it's stuck yeah because I mean
people have to understand that like now
making a superhero movie is like of
course you're going to make a superhero
movie but back then blade is not a
no-brainer blade is something is a bit
of it's another time when you'd say it's
a risk right yes companies would have
thought it was a risk to put that movie
yeah yeah at that time they did yeah and
it becomes this massive franchise look
at that
yeah look at that like talent of God yes
somehow that's so big it swallowed
Stephen Dorff hole so talent of God is a
book telling 'god is the book you always
want to be a novelist not particularly
but you know when you're trained at a
professional bit arts training school
you're kind of conditioned and taught
how to be ambidextrous and do a lot of
different things so you not only perform
but you learn how to work the sets you
learn how to pull cable you learn how to
write your own one-man shows you learn
how to write scenes is that is that
foundation for you though is that
because you're just so invested or is it
part survival mechanism that's about to
graduate yeah you can graduate if you
don't do well with that kick you out of
the school but you do you find yourself
doing so many different things as a
survival mechanism because you know show
business is so no no I'm abundantly
infinitely creative yes and I do a lot
of different things because I'm trying
to explore the boundaries of my
creativity and the book is another
attempt at pushing those boundaries and
seeing you know can I do a high kick and
undo a low kick right spin kick you know
can I do this and people want to believe
too that this is not a good book like
people want to believe that you can't be
good at everything but then Travis was
just in here during the break saying the
reviews I've been great so far
so far so good yeah that is that did you
kind of know though because you know you
know you never know even with a plot you
never know
you don't know you don't know looking at
a union co-writer don't look at it and
go like this is a good book we know you
think is great right we think is to be
on every kitchen table in the world but
we're you know we're in a small minority
what we think like that and it's nice
when you have your great editors we have
a grape and it is that we're working
with us great publishers that we're
working with us when they resonate with
it and they give you a little inkling to
say hey I think we're onto something
here that's comforting right at the end
of the day at the end of the days we
depends on the fans and it depends on
the readers well and your name is on it
it's not representing the editors it's
like that's what right right it's really
like from being a comic I have immediate
feedback and I kind of know which way to
go based on that but for writing a book
you have the feedback of your editor and
your friends and stuff like that but you
don't really know what it is or how it's
being received until you release the
thing that's right it's already finished
you can't change it yeah yeah right and
that's something yet you I've been in a
couple of bad movies like really really
talk about it it's like what that was
not the movie I signed up okay have you
had that experience where you're like on
paper this looks great
we're filming this seems great and then
you go and see this movie and you're
like what is the no we have a movie
coming out now titled armed response
uh-huh and it's a co-production with
Gene Simmons my in Simmons from kiss
sure his new shingle and a partnership
with WWE where I have a multi picture
deal with WWE and we Monte house studios
we have a multi picture deal so we
decided you know I would join the cruise
I would joined ensemble for gene Simmons
is new film right and then I get sent
the poster right you know post is only
me like yeah when gene is right fat
Rolly losing the right Simmons is in the
movie Oh seems like I kind of wanna let
you guys go on the poster have you seen
the movie nah we're sitting there like I
don't remember this being a Wesley
Snipes whole I'm telling you this is
exactly what we asked them right
marketing team it was like yeah but that
was a part of the deal I was like
deal it wasn't my right they started
throwing it back and forth you know I
hope the movies good you know I get the
credit if it's a movies bad and it
wasn't me right good night except except
that's it
that's your face being all over the
poster like wow yeah look at that set
ronsis gets to go back to wrestling
gene Simmons gets to do whatever he
wants to do because it's a Wesley
Sneijder there was a person who wrote in
one of these little blogs or tweets or
something like that
there's maybe Wesley Snipes has come
back we don't see if you know if it's a
hit and it all great he's on the rise
again but if it's not uh
yo um ensemble playing right I
appreciate the love but you know some
spread it around this is becoming this
is becoming your comeback story in your
life that's not I don't know that I
would have signed up for this as the
comebacks angry dude yo they've even put
gene Simmons on the post yeah
tongue yeah yeah not even sound out a
man is tone put them in face paint
whatever you do oh my god the game
that's it yeah that's the business you
have to just like do you get mad at that
in the moment then just brush it aside
cuz you have to move on to the next
thing yes part of the business yeah you
know and uh look if our it's a long
journey this is a marathon right family
if one film doesn't work hey like what
he says we'll get them next time keep
working on it yes part of the reason why
we I got into the writing the book write
which is very cinematic and it lends
itself as a to be a nice template for
what the film could be is that what you
want you want is it been optioned yet
money house controls the rights to it
uh-huh and we at this particular point
have not put it out there so we all can
see with the fan let the reason
readership in the reading communities
action if it's a one in president yeah
and it almost looks like it could be the
Wesley Snipes video game vehicle look
just from the cover and then I'm gonna
do that deuce video games as well of
course you do is this something where if
it became a movie you would want to be
the star of it would you want to be the
director what would you want to with
what would you want to do with this
producing of course yes but I don't know
I am of course is written where the
flavor
the mind of me playing talent yeah the
the holy warrior we will see yeah we'll
see you maybe somebody else down back
there better you know my man over here
you know we wouldn't miss I can never
stop and play the talented I'm sure
non-traditional can't get me on a few of
those I'll have Ryan Reynolds pretty
looking blade Trinity I'll get those up
and then that's the thing too about
being a producer right is that you want
to do whatever is going to make the most
money for the film you have to put your
ego aside or you want to do whatever
best for the film right for the story
right yeah you know and sometimes you
don't insert yourself into everything
I'm comfortable with my myself and who
Wesley is he doesn't need to be you know
and everything and everywhere and all
the time did you become difficult to
work with at any point because I mean
you had this run like not many people
have had run and I mean you talk about
so I heard you physical right that's
what I heard you know but of course of
course when you when you are focused on
quality yes and you're working with
people who don't have your pedigree or
don't have your skillset of course
they're gonna call you difficult that
goes with the territory but you're like
you guys are not my level the proof is
in the pudding right right let the
product speak for itself
yeah now we can go back to the videotape
you remember when I told you yeah and I
mean look that's what that when you're
sitting there talking about a marathon
and this being a comeback movie in this
book being this and that regardless at
the end of the day you've got more
movies than most that have last lasted
forever I mean you do white men can't
jump new jack city are coming everything
just iconic after iconic after iconic
money-train all these these giant hands
were wrapped on J Lo's tips how could
that will last forever there's a good
time
Kermit don't bring it there's a whole
lot of people don't want to use their
about this watch but it was fun yeah
yeah grab entities with oh yeah it is
regal winners
you want to leave it yeah what's great
about movies that like you have way more
opportunity to grab titties than in
regular life right I don't know about
the hooters I mean if I ran oh who the
franchise ever I hold is involved and
probably even at the boss your
responsibility does about the durability
is correct that's true it is a
responsibility what do you think of of
what people are talking about now people
are talking about not only blade being
remade but white men can't jump
being remade and I was watching white
men can't jump last night and like
looking at it in the context of 2017 and
it was like the whole movie was about
the comedy of differences between white
people between black people between men
between women between Puerto Rican
between and like that's not the culture
that we live in anymore like it doesn't
seem like the type of thing that would
lend itself to remain on a Colorado teen
right now it were kind of polarized and
we don't like talking about differences
we like acting like well just bringing
that up is a bad thing you know you know
it's a little always a little different
on the court Yeah right there the
camaraderie and the banter is always
different in sports sports field so that
might be a you know a microcosm of the
world that actually appreciates that
kind of those kind of sensibilities yeah
well do you think it's something that
could be successfully remade or that
you'd want to see it remade we have a
saying if it ain't broke don't fix it
right you know so if they do great if it
works okay that's cool you know we woody
and I we did what we did and it's going
to stand and people still resonate with
it for forever you know generation after
generation are introduced to that work
and they appreciate it so I would have
much more interested in seeing the
sequel of you and and what he's still
playing like as write in the variety
your playgrounds where our confidence
yeah right the sting so we had an idea
of actually doing a version of the sting
and a version of white men can't jump in
the
confidence game type of car something
that we've been toying around with for a
number of years ago well and I'm a
basketball guy and I heard you couldn't
play before the movie yeah really
offended by that it really got out
though right it was like what are you
talking about but at the time you know
at that time I well the street ball oh
yeah but I had been focusing a lot more
than martial arts so I didn't have the
handle that I had when I was really
playing ball in the Bronx on a day to
day basis and by the time we got to
audition for the the film an audition of
which they called in every actor in
Hollywood Wow from the brat pack to the
rat pack to you really
everybody audition they did a
three-on-three and I did a form for Y
and on occasions they might do a full
court I went in and I auditioned I
didn't hit a shot everything I thought
was a strength what I took [ __ ] so they
were actually the producers actually
laughing about this like maybe it is
shot but you don't know was there
anybody on the auditioning there that
like intimidated you like I'm not going
to get the role over this guy all of the
plays that was all that's right oh I had
Charlie Sheen though I don't know I'm
worried about that oh and Charlie Sheen
there I was way we've seen the smoking
cigarettes between points yeah can you
believe all of them catch the audition
for that movie
panting crowd of everybody in Hollywood
they auditioned to everybody Wow we
played basketball
twenty-four seven three six days a week
we shot and we played basketball when we
got to work we got played basketball
while we were working we played
basketball at lunch and we played
basketball after we're at and you and
what he got along obviously oh yeah to
this day we still go can you imagine the
torture that would have been if they had
cast it and it was just some douchebag
that you didn't like like how do you do
it that very different movie right he
different I think that scene where he's
trying to get you in his own and get you
pissed off would have happened a lot
easier
he was it how much of it was ad-libs and
how much of it was scripted because we
were at some
we're talking about that like so much of
the [ __ ] talking especially on your end
like there is so much [ __ ] coming out of
your mouth you had such a speed but it's
all like goddamn that he stays like you
know what I mean like did stuff that Ron
shelters good Sheldon right friend great
director he gave us a lot of leeway in
that he wanted it to feel like it does
when you're playing street ball you know
give us that freedom so that kind of
thing you can't actually right right you
know and if you try to ride it then and
respond in the moment you probably will
forget the line yeah he gave us some
freedom but it was very well structured
very well structured very well directed
when blade becomes the success that it
became do you start feeling like
invincible because I mean it's just like
because you were so hands-on with that
do you feel like that's a different
movie Sam no it's awesome really but you
know like you go hit hit hit hit you
know you're obviously of this string of
hits but like you were so a part of that
blade franchise and like you said not
everybody thought that this would be as
successful as what he really went at
that time they didn't give me the credit
for the contribution it was presumed and
assumed that there were other people who
were behind the success or should be
credited for the success of the film and
also I didn't really know at that time
how it was resonating with the world
that was still very unclear um so yeah
you don't have the Twitter feed back or
anything I would have anything and so
you happen right across the country
right now not yeah this was kind of like
wow this is resonating I remember there
was a moment when they did a screening
of the film and I think Bob Shaye who
was the president of Lionsgate at the
time if my memory serves me right he was
sitting in the back and someone
overheard him saying why do people like
this
[Laughter]
it was already made he's like I don't
get it one people like this good it's
good at the support of the company yeah
really yeah thanks I won't take a chip
finish but it was successful that's that
the that's the deal behind it but did
you know this the beauty of this
situation here would tell
God again we get to control it from the
beginning to the end we have a lot more
say in how the film is going to be put
together if we when we get to it
by the grace of God we in this
particular book is we we've planned it
to be one of a trilogy it's a standalone
project now territory now with a
closed-in but it also opens the door for
the second and the third so we have to
see where the film fits in and right
time into one filming the three films is
it yeah yeah do you do a film before you
release the second book right all of
these kind of things you know right
because our our Martin is a beauty of
having some influence and control over
your own creativity now you can work
with you know and design how it's going
to roll out you have like-minded people
and individuals who are focused on the
best strategy for the film was best
strategy for the IP as a whole at what
point did you realize that control was
that important because a lot of actors
are just actors right they go in they do
their acting they think thing namely oh
my gosh when I was doing a couple of
films that I did in Europe or a couple
of films and we would get I would get
accused or the actor would be accused of
the success or the failure of the film
and it which is kind of mind-boggling
when you consider that filmmaking is so
collaborative right so many people
involved and the marketing team
sometimes doesn't communicate with the
production team and the production team
doesn't doesn't communicate with the
director so there's a lot a lot of
people a lot of hands in the pot in
making films and you're like if I'm
going to get blamed for this I need to
take control of it when right about when
the weekend box office numbers come out
is it uh Wesley Snipes film was a flop
returns over these nice field is on the
rise oh yeah well it's like the
quarterback getting the blame after his
defense gives up 50 points right yeah
you're right you're the head grow to
date on it how did how did you you know
your your troubles it with tax evasion
were documented how do I was never
charged with tax evasion what were you
charged way I don't want a well we'll
come back to that you know we will
there's going to be a tough because you
don't know the whole story I'm quite
sure right I'm sure not yeah most people
don't right
right there would be time that was going
to come to time we're going to have a
very good conversation but but you might
want to do your research and that way
you'll understand what really went down
you get rid over a little bit well it
depends on who's asking where and I like
I look forward to that conversation
because I mean that's usually having tax
problems I'm not not yet but I hope not
knowingly right sure I mean right a
whole lot of people that won't admit
that they have tax problems right now -
I'm quite sure yeah I'm here the
governor has a whole day I quiet
covering up the t-word don't bring up
the whole studio real quiet how did the
how did your perspective change though
after after you got out and it's time to
go back to work
are you are you a different person or
was it just your going to be a different
person every day right change is
inevitable that's the only constant that
there really is right so of course
you're going to be elevated by your wins
and your losses but when you go through
fire it makes you better that's how you
make the greatest swords they kind of
put through fire
you got it has to be yeah killed you got
to view the layers and layers and layers
to make it strong and build up that
tensile strength so I'm not stronger now
than I was before
damn right Yeah right there i film
undisputed before you went in or was
that after do your research I know but
my favorite entity terrible wonder you
loved that movie and it's based on my
face and right [ __ ] you targeted I
mind I never weathered harder [ __ ] are
you talking about I'm high like in
terrible question
I don't know hobby so I know I bring it
on professionals in here well you should
have a reasonable kill you demon here if
I could get baptized by Wesley Snipes on
the radio boy would that make for a nice
women well that's what the reading
talent of God will do for you it's a
baptism by Wesley Snipes right there
everybody should check out this book
especially because it's a it's a it's a
novel it's like a supernatural thriller
as you said cinematic based supernatural
thriller yeah are the forces of evil the
Fallen Angels are having
on going invisible battle with the holy
host yeah and the warriors of light and
a holy warrior is tasked with protecting
a young woman who doesn't know that
she's been chosen by the Almighty to be
to carry the Sword of Truth Wow
so - justice and you got action we got
to me that drama
we got suspense a little 48 hours in
there why are you laughing
oh no I'm enjoying this yeah